hello inch and welcome to the co playing
international acids are wrong be 27 22
are you kidding me as an i am again
anyway sometimes these are GM's but they
didn't they have napped yet informed ICC
to update GM with 27 and 500 and IM with
27 and five minutes pretty and pretty
remarkable zombie it's an uncommon and
we should take c5 it of course not a bad
move it just just uncommon night 86 is
the usual way um black players handle
this pollution you can probably always
build up ahead shock g4 is an
interesting move in this position I
wonder if this is a this is something
that gets dry it's it's certainly
interesting you can go g5 Bishop g3
takes g4 than h4 and and he does that
must be some kind of compensation you
know probably probably pretty good
compensation oh that's something real
crazy on yeah like 93 takes g4 okay then
look g one that doesn't work
and yes but it doesn't work right what
is he doing here and I just have this
one while you just place this position
of course and this is this as possible
hmm but one we should be three or what's
the deal proof Wow okay hmm let's think
about this for a moment voice Bishop 'if
i had the most precise move
f4 is also possible Wow very tough very
tough okay pawn takes rook g1 check King
edge a bishop if I check f-16 g6 is
winning for Wyatt let much I saw so we
cannot just take laughs use for vets day
to this connection uh-huh oh ok I mean
as thought I'm willing and the engine
confirms that white is winning but I
disconnects what's going on yeah I
pretty don't know yeah anyway I thought
I thought this is really a risk here
this is g 5 business yeah i mean first
of all if it does I mean if it doesn't
play that however it is it is dangerous
here the engine wants to go b5 very cool
reply if he plus play something normal I
mean this is probably McCain has 9 h 7
so this doesn't even work look g1 maybe
now it's dangerous nth Froy the computer
thinks widest what's quite quite a bit
better it looks very risky really ok
this this this and now yeah i was first
of all I was thinking maybe Luke g1 but
then he has this and here ok the
computer finds bishops is 7 and this
chance and white has a winning attack
the computer concludes but ok this is a
bit hard for a human player but this was
good yeah he cannot take because of the
shyness this chechik f-16 g6 this is
what I saw that that I'm winning yeah
threatening
some mates and he cannot cannot defend
them all so we cannot take the the night
and then my next move is rook to g1 so
if he goes here for example I can go to
g1 anyway because this is a chance
position this is what i saw when i
played bishop at forum so I'm
essentially keeping the peace yeah as I
get in rupee g1 and move the night and
then I'm attacking with an extra piece
yeah pretty strange game by the super
hydrated player and then the disconnect
maybe it was real disconnect but it
could also could be some kind of
frustration disconnect you never know ok
well thanks for watching